so
those young ladies down there
they seem
exceedingly alive
they haven't yet made any untold
advances but perhaps you could speak to
them
verify their intentions are civil
only that they appear to have some
vested interest in accessing the vault
one seemed quite perturbed when i told
them that wouldn't be happening
but i'm not sure
i've been keeping watch here long enough
to have learned that
i'm sorry to say it
well yes but it's been some time
until quite recently it's i maintained
my post
greeted latecomer but very recently it
seems people have come back to apple
it's all very cons
oh do be careful out there sir
whoa whoa
just a friend here not a threat
just had some questions for you
you came out of the vault right i
thought it was empty
wait is the door still open
god damn it
we got a tip from the wayward
heard of the place new bard down the
road so this guy told us that
after you gave him the last of our caps
and he said that inside that vault is
the
you know
that's where the big one is our last
chance to turn our lousy luck around
you know the thing that brought everyone
back
the treasure
i knew it
see you selling it wasn't a scam
[Music]
sure sir is there any way for us to
actually get inside there
that's what i thought
wait there's no way in
but
those are the last of our caps
no
someone has to know something we're just
gonna stick it out until we find them
wonderful
thanks for answering some questions for
us i suppose
seems only fair i return the favor
anything we can answer for you
oh now that you mention it i guess i
could spare these
here
happy to tell you what i know which
isn't much
someone made a broadcast not too long
back about there being some kind of
treasure with people as desperate as
they are it's meant everyone with a
function
monster cern guy we met at the wayward
carter i think was his name he gave us
up to us now to make
about appalachia
other than it's a graveyard there's that
we haven't been here real long but from
what we
the area got hit pretty hard
not long after
this
they're merciless they seem to have
clean without people
watch yourself out
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
i suppose your conversation with those
two seemed
wow
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
uh
uh
[Applause]
uh
so
[Applause]
uh
well fed
that's hard work making out here
[Applause]
[Applause]
uh
okay
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
[Applause]
uh
uh
this
duchess let you try one of her drams yet
word of advice
keep it to one
uh
lady i will paint the walls with you if
you don't tell me where crane's treasure
is right now
sweetheart i think you must be sick
because pointing a gun at me in my own
bar is a terminal affliction
look around
you think i'm having my people piece
this place together out of mobile homes
cause i'm thrifty
do i look like a honey
you picked the wrong time to get a drink
what are you hey where the hell are you
outnumbered i [ __ ]
fine but don't think this is the end
only for you honey
no one pulls a gun on me in my bar
mort
get out here yeah what duchess
jesus
you look one of those monsters in here
hey you want to see if there's a
tomorrow then i want you to tell me
where you and the rest of your non-skull
crew is hiding out
wha what
mort what was that
called me a monster all right what
he was gonna kill us
i
you know
we could have asked him some questions
oh
you know what it's safer this way anyway
i suppose
now i'm hoping you're here to have a
drink and play nice
i've had a gun pointed at me more than
enough for one day
uh
so
huh well not exactly the introduction to
the wayward i would have hoped for
well sorry about that darling
first round's on me
names duchess
there's something i could do for you
your guess is as good as mine sweetheart
he busted in here saying i needed to
turn over the location of some fellow
named crane who i guess i must have
served at some point or another since
then a steady stream of miscreants has
been making my life irritating
not exactly good for a budding business
now that you mention it i could use an
extra pair of hands
see
that boy we put down
he's not the first of his crew to roll
in here but i want him to be the last
normally i'd send my people out to clean
house but my muscles run off so i don't
have the bodies to spare right now
but i'm willing to pay good money if you
put an end to this for me
so
what do you say
that's what i was hoping
so
the details
now
each of these boys came in asking after
crane
i'm thinking we can make that work for
us how would you grab the attention of a
bunch of single-minded thugs
bingo
exactly what i'm thinking
just give me one second
okay i think i'll just
i just want you to know architecture
ain't exactly my forte
huh not half bad
so what i have chicken scratched
together here for you is the schematic
for one custom-made crane treasure
hunting ink sign if i didn't butcher the
plans too bad it's got a little system
built in that'll make sending out an
advertisement and getting this gang's
attention a snap
you just need to build it use the tape
it spits out to tell the world you're
open for business and then convince any
punks that show up to tell you where
their boss is hiding they did teach you
all how to build from schematics up in
that vault of yours didn't they
that's the spirit
hey if you need a refresher good old
morty mort can help you out what are you
on about mordecai
hey now i'm not bragging or anything but
i've got some tapes that cover that very
subject
oh mort not the tapes well you find
yourself wanting a refresher
talk to mort
of course you're gonna need materials
but we should have enough lying around
to cover you there
get you together a little care package
throw some rations in there too so you
don't starve on me
and so you know you might have to break
some of this scrap down for parts
but i can spot you some workbench
materials too since you're doing me such
a big one
who knows
maybe you'll learn something while you
do it
now you ready to get this show on the
road
it is a lot to ask fine
i could do
75
but that's as high as i'll go
that means you're up to the task
hot dog
be good to have those adults off our
back at long last
just make sure once you find out where
they're hiding
that their leader gets the message
the wayward gets left alone
oh and on the topic of leaders
you know one of my people found this
tape in the camp across the way recorded
by one overseer of vault 76
it's
a little out of date at this point
but it seems it might have been left for
someone from her vault
maybe it was waiting for you
sounds like she set the camp up so her
people could get some practice in
self-reliance
probably worth looking into if you think
you could use a little refresher